ん
私この地球上での様をやっています
高見沢ています
正確には
地球上の日本このうち野辺山高原です
最初に
私のちょっと個人自己判断による
性格とか欠点を皆さんにお話ししたいと思います
最初にまず私はひねくれています
決して素直ではありません
それかですね集団行動は
かなり苦手です
あとですねー
瞬間湯沸かし器みたいなところがあります
すごい住む気になってしまう
あと
ちょっとのラインの的な性格っていうんでしょうか
あのうろうろうろうろうろうろするの大好きです
あとねー
ちょっといっぱいありすぎてねは困っちゃうぐらいなんですが諦めが悪いとか
計画性が全くない
おまけで長男ときて手をよ結婚できたが多いと言う
まぁそそのくらいなんですけど
あと
あの妙な癖がありまして
人の足元目のすごい好きで
悪い意味じゃないですよあの
靴大好きです
あの
そこ歩行の動物が考えた靴ってすごいと思いませんか
すごい機能的であったりおしゃれであったり
や山登る靴走る苦痛
女子そういうところになぜか惹かれちゃいます
シューズフェチって言うんですかね
まあいろんな曲それから変な性格あるんですがここからはちょっと皆さんあの気持ちを
ニュートラルにして聴いてみてください
あの私冗談のような本当の話
本当のような冗談の話が
多分出てきちゃうと思います
気持ちをちょっとニュートラルにして聴いてみてください
もともと私の農家ではありません
もともとわぁ前職はえっとテレビ cm 等の
広告のアートデザイナーディレクターを目指してました
かっこいいショートです
当然流行りの仕事であり
クリエイタークリエイターって呼ばれる仕事です
でも
仕事非常に充実してて楽しかったんですがある撮影の時に
雑誌に目がとまりました
その雑誌の見出しに書いてあったのが
日本のデザインはカートリッジである
イタリアのデザイナー巨匠所ジェット10時あろうの言葉です
その時徹夜続きでちょっとうつろではあったんですが
強烈にここに月安泰入りました
確かに広告の仕事
経済企業の発展には
必要な仕事かと思いますでもサイクルが早すぎます
あくまでスポンサーの商品を売るための仕事じゃないかなって
そこで私覚悟しました
生命の源クリエイトできたらなって
農業です
これ本当ですよ冗談のような本当なあああ
本当の話です今から25年前バブル期ですが
会社のみんなには
なんだあなたどうしたの
oo に考えがちあんた彼女に振られたとか
だいたいそのくらいのほど言葉しか返ってこないですよね
もうそこは私のも決断です
さてこのエリアの野辺山高原の野菜なんですがちょっとお話します
レタス白菜キャベツと夏の冷涼な気候を生かした野菜作りが行われています
キャベツですね
あの気持ちを貼っを
あの new とランディスてあの日傾けてくださいね
アークないですね
あのこのような葉物野菜このエリアでつくるっていうのは非常に安定しています
周年も安定してますしかし私はこのエリアで誰も取り組んだ
取り組んだことのない
前例のないと元を始めました
緑の野菜の中に赤があったっていいじゃないか
なぜやらなかったんでしょうか今まで
確かな冬マイナス25度にもなるようなアイディアです
ここでは無理だとか無茶だとか無駄っていう
どうしてもそういうとこから入ってしまいます皆さん石橋はたたけど
渡らないです
なんか非常に寂しいです
私は石破氏はた誰か叩かないけど渡っちゃうタイプのね
非常に性格ひねくれています皆と同じの集団行動は嫌だって言う
欠点が
なぜか
土間とになりました
標高1350m 昼夜の気温差
日射量の多さあトマトの原産地ってどこだってかなって思ったら
まあこれは取り組まない手はないわと
いうことです
私農業を始めた時に
このようなものを作る作家活動もしてました
私作家目
一生です
いろいろな作品
あるのですが
本日こちらでお持ちしたのはあの晩犬のポチです
ポチですねあと他にもいろいろあります
これがいいんでしょうこれ適当なあの名前つけてますねこれぽっちですね
これてんとう虫5章です
これか負けちょっと人間の雄と雌をちょっと関係をちょっと描きたかったですね
重たいけどこれ魚ですいろいろ作りました
でこのポチなんですが
ぽつであるわけないですよね
見ての通りです
これ何でできてるかっていうと
壊れてしまったトラクターと可能キング
農具の廃材でできています
その昔
その昔のトラクタってなんだっけかなって思ったときに
お星じゃん
まじゃない
それを現代のトラクターの部品や
脳筋で再現してみました
壊れてしまったり摩耗したりしてしまうとスクラップとなってしまうんですが
その前にもう一度敬意を表そうと命を吹き込もうと思って
作成しました
あと今日本日あのこの会場の入口に巨大なぁの
連頃を持ってきたんですけど
ですねカブト星です
何か皆さんに感じていただければ楽しいなと思います
連れてのこのようなもの農機具の形をそのまんま生かして作成しています
難しい理屈は
入れません
彼等を見て
それをどこに当て込んで作っていこうかということをいつも考えています
100個できたら私百姓になろうと思います
一勝二章3章ヨイショ最後百姓に私解明しようかなって
つまんない等あるてすいません
私あのこのようなことをやりながらこの地でトマトを作ったことで
私のと窓を
中国でも作っていただけませんかという依頼が来ました
ここで作った事が
ここだけではなくてさらに海外での生産指導
アドバイザーにもつながりました
今までフィリピンとか
中国各地これゴビ砂漠のふもとです
あちらこちらに入って個人としていって
トマト作りの
生産指導を行っていますがあくまでも何かを持って行くのではなくて現地の
週刊風洞し原資材を活用した方法です
そこでには
想像力が求められます
前職であった
cm を作る仕事栗8すること
サラねそこで日本企画の甘いトマト
トマト
そうですね
わかりますか
トマトの美味しさって
身の
こういう部分と薄い部分のグラデーションがはっきりと分かれているのは美味しい証拠
です
糖度約10度以上は超えてます
これを減じで作ろうと
いうことです
ただ主
砂漠の中
砂漠の中での生産は
ハードルは非常に高いです塩害であったり
資材不足であったりいろいろあるんですが
そのハードルを越えた時克服できた時の
トマト
みるともう自己満足の木は火です
正直います
m 男です
ハードルが高ければ高いほど
楽しいんです循環湯沸かし器ねムキになっています
いろいろ私経験してきましたが
何か一つのものをつくり上げようとするとき
いろいろな経験それから
自分の性格欠点とも思われる性格を
一つの部品としたときに
それをどうやって結びつけるかで
形が出来てくるのではないかなって思っています
その時
一つの工程一つの作業をそれぞれが
何か一つでも抜けてしまったらこれ
3巻前であって不完全であったり
完成しないのではないでしょうかこれもそうです何かなかったらきっと出来上がって来
ないかと思います
その作業無心になって行う作業にどれだけの価値があるかと
私は捉えています
ベッドをしても私たち出来上がった物に対してすごい価値を感じてしまうかもしれませ
ん
いや速攻そう
それではなくて
何かを作ろうとして
公園に移しているときその
1工程の位置作業それも身になってを行っている自分
それが自分を育てたり支えたりしています
その経営経過
プロセスですねさらにプラス自分の欠点とも言える性格までが
逆に立ってきます2一つのツールになります
アイデアの一つ
アイデアの一つを
行動に移すとき
またそれらを無心になって
作業をしているとき
この行為に対して
そんなの
無理無理そんなのむちゃむちゃそんなの無駄だよ
それは決してないと思います
72億分の1
ポジティブなおじさんた上座でした
ありがとうございました